today are alternative views our guest is
John downing professor of communications
at the University of Texas John is
author of the book radical media an
editor of film and politics and the
third world and question in the media
today we're going to discuss with John
the difference between mainstream and
alternative media in the United States
and we'll discuss ways that you can get
various sources alternative sources of
information and entertainment in the US
and where the oppositional media are we
use the term on alternative use a lot
establishment media and alternative
media these four words really have a lot
of meaning behind them and imply a lot
of things what can you tell us about
those to establishment an alternative
media I think established media
basically media which in one way are
subtly or not so subtly represent the
views of the establishment of the of the
power structure of the society
alternative media can take a variety of
forms I mean the word is very loose it
alternative could mean an extreme latest
publication like a KKK publication it
could mean something which is just
different like some golfing specialist
magazine
it could mean some of the high-level
secret briefing papers which are
delivered to the president and the
cabinet and nobody else is allowed to
see in my use and in terms of the work
I've done I've looked more at
small-scale grassroots radical
oppositional media and that is those are
the kind of media that I really know
about and I hope we can talk about some
more John let's give some examples of
what mainstream or corporate media are
and then some examples of alternative
media in terms of the press wouldn't you
say that papers like The Wall Street
Journal and The New York Times USA Today
and the Washington Post our sort of
national newspapers or the mainstream
newspapers sure along with the networks
and Fox and so on yeah absolutely and
the news magazines Time and Newsweek
right exactly but if you're wanting
alternative then not all of the national
but you could look at a whole variety of
things you could look at the alternative
computer information network peace net
you could look at deep dish satellite
television you could look at alternative
views you could look at a whole variety
of small video projects which which
everywhere you would look at papers like
in these times or Mother Jones the list
is endless there's a huge number there's
even the thing called the Utne leader
which is a digest of the alternative
media which gives you some sense of how
how many of them there are but they're
very often small-scale and underfinanced
and the ugly readers now has a large
distribution something like two hundred
and fifty thousand and it's supplanted
Mother Jones is the most widely read of
the alternative media okay well we
talked about the establishment media and
the establishment the power structure
how do you see that in the United States
you use in your book the term ruling
class and power structure what are you
describing I'm describing a relationship
which is not quite as simple and blatant
and overt as it used to be in the former
Soviet Union where the mainstream media
there were very careful to accurately to
reflect the views of the power structure
with a one-time here the relationship is
not quite so simple to grasp but I think
what it comes to in the end is it on
crucial issues the mainstream media here
will almost always exactly reflect the
views of the power structure and only
when that power structure is itself
divided seriously divided about a
particular issue like let us say in the
later stages of the Southeast Asian war
at that point then the mainstream media
may come
to reflect those divisions and it looks
as though they're being oppositional
whereas in fact it's more that they're
aligning themselves or some of them with
aligning themselves with one wing of the
power structure which is at odds with
another wing now most Americans are not
used to seeing or hearing such a thing
is that I mean after all we're democracy
and the people rule right there's no
ruling class in fact I've had classes at
the University of Texas where they say
that no such thing is a class structure
and when I was studying the u.s. power
structure in the mass media there was
only one class in which any of this was
taught only one on the whole campus for
11 years and so people are not used to
hearing this type of thing and yet the
ruling class itself is very much aware
of its existence and function Scotty
Reston you had a quote in your book he
talked about the intelligent minority
yes well I mean in spite of the the
rhetoric a lot of rhetoric about
democracy in this country and some
reality there's also a large measure of
hypocrisy and people will talk very
readily about how democratic this
country is that it is the most
democratic country in the world and I
would that it was so and I would that
all countries were so democratic as this
one is claimed to be the fact remains
that repeatedly when it comes to the
crunch on crucial issues that democracy
just is shorn away and naked power is is
evident let's turn now Tilly is
alternative press or radical press is a
name of your book and they of course are
the dissenters now there's a quote which
you have and I'd like you to talk about
this you talked about the strict ceiling
on significant dissent by the American
power structure can you explain a little
bit further
well I think that ceiling on significant
dissent shows itself in two ways that is
to say there are many alternative media
which have operated flourished ground
and resurrected even without seeming
interference by the power structure but
at points at which they seemed to be
threatening the can of the any kind of
exposed nerve as defined by the power
structure at that point the the amount
of kind of repression directed against
these small-scale media is really
extraordinary we tend to think of these
media as being well maybe nothing much
matters and they're pretty Picayune and
so on the power structure tends not to
share that view oddly enough and there
are many examples I mean if you look at
the kind of surveillance of black media
in the United States during World War
two when they were the only media
significantly raising the question of
segregation in the Armed Forces and they
came within a whisker of all being
closed down if you look at the the the
media during the Vietnam War and the way
in which rather than simply close them
down by strict and overt government
censorship people would approach the
landlord and get the landlord to cancel
the lease or to jack up the vents to an
impossible point news vendors would be
have asked during the McCarthy era new
stands which carried the Guardian and
other newspapers would be would be told
not to do it people in small towns who
subscribed would get a visit from the
FBI and be told that they were being
disloyal by even subscribing to and
reading this newspaper it's quite
extraordinarily the lengths to which the
pass structure will go at a point at
which it is decided that one of these
small outlets which has nothing like the
circulation or audience of the of the
major media one of these small outlets
is saying things which ought not to be
said I understand there are other
examples like the FBI getting people
fired from their jobs even bombing or
died
fighting presses and getting
particularly record companies to cease
advertising in some of these underground
newspapers they recall that well we saw
it recently with the ice cube the track
about the police and the LA riots I mean
that was a classic case in point of Ice
Cube it's a rap group that had a song
about cop killer oh okay and I thought
it was a new magazine there's a lot of
pressure to take that off of the market
but you know with the alternative press
today I don't see that repression or
isn't going on I don't realize don't see
any interference and public access
television or you're more you're real
familiar with the print media and are is
this going on at all today I am not
aware of it if it is well it is with
different groups like the political
groups activist groups like sis past for
instance or the Socialist Workers Party
but what about the alternate again I
mean it depends what's going on I mean
by and large American politics have been
relatively quiet for the last dozen or
so years with the exception I would say
of two major forces one was the
anti-nuclear movement and the other one
was various forms of particularly
African American struggle but the
problem is I think we can say well I
don't think there's so much going on
because you don't maybe get to hear
about it but this is a vast country very
often the repression is directed against
some relatively small group that doesn't
have a national voice some local
community activity which doesn't have
some national amplification and so very
often stuff is in fact going on that
even those of us who are aware of these
issues and lead the stuff and watch the
stuff a list of the stuff don't actually
get to hear about so I'd be cautious
about saying it's not happening there's
a subtle way that a certain amount of
repression of the alternative media took
place during the Reagan and Bush years
and that is they up the postal rates
instantly so that it became more and
more expensive to publish alternative
publications and so several went out of
business simply because of this John
let's talk about what a Democratic
Society should be and what the role of
the press in a democratic society should
be and actually it seems to me that the
founding fathers had at least the start
in defining a Democratic a genuinely
Democratic role for the media you
mentioned this in your book radical
media how did the founding fathers
conceive of the role of the media in a
Democratic Society I don't think they
were necessarily quite as democratic
themselves as some of some of us are
today but the fact remains that in their
time they were certainly very radical by
comparison with what is what was going
on in the rest of the world and I think
they saw the media as their best as
providing a variety of you see some of
the founding fathers did a variety
abused the opportunity for a free
exchange of opinions about issues of the
day which would enable hopefully the the
best wisdom to emerge on how to tackle
the problems of the day given the fact
there is no magical source of
information about how to tackle the
problems of the day we have only our own
resources and so we need to exchange our
views and even modify our views in that
process of exchange and weren't the
media also conceived by the founding
fathers as a check against corruption
and excessive power there was an
incredibly radical concept for the day
because previously the media had been
tightly controlled by absolutist states
where the media were just simply not
allowed to press we were talking about
mainly in print media we're not allowed
to criticize the state or they were
subject to censorship whereas the United
States set up a bill of rights which
gave freedom of the press and there was
actual discussion that this was the role
of the press was to attack corruption
was to criticize the state to be a
watchdog to the state to what extent has
have the media in this society and
particularly today really assumed that
role or they become more sort of lap
dogs of the state and a corporate power
structure as opposed to say watchdogs I
would say very little by way of
watchdogs unfortunately the the kind of
cases the people typically quote saying
for the power of the oppositional press
the the attack on McCarthy in 1954 and
Watergate and the attack on McCarthy was
indeed in 1954 he had been in full spate
for four years at that point and why
they attacked him was he eventually went
after the army and indeed not just the
army that the military top brass in
terms of Nixon it was as I rightly
recall the Washington Post and Public
Television which were the only two media
sources that in any way followed up the
Watergate story until it had been right
through an election and the other side
of an election then when it appeared
that there was something in it then you
got the kind of the pact journalism
syndrome where everybody launched in and
and you couldn't move without getting
Watergate material but that PAC
journalism is not my definition of an
independent and stubborn press I think
if I could clarify something or try to
regarding the founding fathers when we
talk about founding fathers I always say
well which which group who are the
founding fathers because the people who
were in the Continental Congress and
signed the Declaration of Independence
were not the same people who signed the
Constitution and the people who sat in
secrecy in Philadelphia and devised this
Constitution were not in favor of the
First Amendment under the Bill of Rights
which brought us freedom to the press
this was forced upon them as a
compromise after they brought out the
Constitution there was so much
opposition in the
that a lot of books say than ever if
there had been free and fair universal
elections in never would have passed
there was lot of chicane Ritu get the
Constitution passed but they finally by
saying okay will ik will let you pass
the Bill of Rights in the first ten
amendments if you'll okay the
Constitution I did it so it was the
founding fathers in Philadelphia who
necessarily were for this they were
purely the good old white boy rich
establishment and also the press itself
there were a lot of repressive laws at
that time which we don't have now a lot
of censorship and libel laws which were
quite restrictive then so we've come a
long way from the time of the founding
fathers well II they did pass the Alien
and Sedition laws right after
practically the Bill of Rights was
signed that was basically a censorship
law so what happened when the radio and
broadcasting first came on the scene how
was this conceptualized as supposedly
serving the interests of the democratic
of a Democratic Society well initially
of course there was a period of
free-for-all which included a period
when frequencies were overlapping with
each other and some stations were much
more powerful than others would drown
each other out and so on and that period
of maybe temporarily chaos was seized
upon both here and also in in Britain as
an argument for a certain kind of
regulation and so at that point
regulation of the Airways swung in and
in some sense that ultimately it took a
while for it ultimately realized but
that ultimately the the same laws of
free competition so calmed which applied
to soap powder or shoes were applied
also to this public resource which was
the airwaves and the laws of the market
prevailed and the result was that
the the airwaves became fairly quickly
dominated by two and then three major
networks and that persisted until very
recently when now we have cable and the
fourth Network I suppose Fox but I could
talk more about the extent to which that
is or isn't offering a plurality of
views if you want but nonetheless what
is evident in broadcast as well as the
press media print media is the way that
ownership is concentrated in major
corporations for the most part and so
those influences which determine which
kind of shoes and cars and aeroplanes
and guns and bullets and bombs are
produced are the same influences which
are very influential a very operative in
determining the kind of news we have the
kind of entertainment we get John people
like Ben mag Dickey and have written
make very good books about the
concentration of ownership of the media
and how the control is in fewer and
fewer hands but even if the control were
not in fewer and fewer hands if a lot of
people own the media they'd still be
owned by capitalists and they'd be for
profit organizations would we see
anything much different from what we see
now do you think probably not although
sometimes it depends of course always
how you define difference I mean let's
take Fox for example which now has a lot
of programs very popular with a younger
audience they're different The Simpsons
are different but they're only different
in the sense that the three main
networks were once described recently
actually actually in the Wall Street
Journal as the bland leading the bland
and so to that extent Fox is not bland
and in that sense it's alternative but
if you if you stand back and say well
never mind that it's alternative the
network's
does it really give a voice to those
people who are habitually shut out of
the media then of course the answer is
no it's just different certain different
formats which are you know a change of
the Kaleidoscope in terms of
entertainment
the tragedy of the American system of
media that from the very beginning we've
had basically commercial media
established in the United States in
Britain in almost every European country
and in most socialist countries and in
third-world countries they had
state-supported broadcasting not
necessarily state-controlled
broadcasting but state-financed
broadcasting as in Europe like in
Holland and Britain where you have
public corporations that are independent
of government set up to try to give
broadcasting system that genuinely
provides information that provides a
wide range of views and entertainment at
least that's the theory
of European media and to some extent the
practice of it whereas almost from the
beginning we've had commercial corporate
media that basically were geared to sell
advertising and thus to provide
entertainment of the lowest common
denominator to attract broad audiences
and that were owned and controlled by
corporations that had their own agenda
that is a corporate agenda to strengthen
the capitalist system and that that's
the system of mainstream media that
emerged in the United States so that
we've never really had any particularly
in the broadcasting Specter until public
access TV as we will soon see and as the
audience is now seen but until then it's
basically just been the voices of
corporate America that you've heard on
broadcasting well I think the definitely
the problem is the definition of the
Airways has has not looked at the
airwaves as a resource like air or water
which are fundamental to any society's
health and well-being and so important
that it is inappropriate to leave these
simply to the imperatives of making
money a society deserves to have certain
resources which cannot be simply
contaminated by that by the logic of
profit and so that's one thing the
second thing is of course that typically
over here people have assumed that if
government is ever involved in media it
is automatically a tremendously
constraining
for
and I mean we could have a whole program
on this but there have been so many
variations of the forms of state
involvement in broadcasting in Europe
from the Dutch system where it has
reflected for a long time the different
religious traditions of that society to
the German tradition whereby after World
War Two they very determinedly put
control over broadcasting at province
level instead of a national level in
order to avoid any possibility of an
overly strong central government of
izing and dominating the media system to
the British system which has had a
competitive channels some state-owned
and some commercial I mean the whole
varieties of ways of doing this none of
which need involves some kind of
top-heavy government interference in the
various alternative media there seem to
be constant political turmoil in all of
these sometimes that would do a great
detriment of these various publications
or organizations is that endemic to the
alternative press um its frequent but I
think political turmoil and clashes
between people about political issues
are pretty normal in you know in in
political life but in these media I
think sometimes particularly in the in
the 70s in the late 60s and early 70s I
was particularly visible perhaps at that
point because people had sometimes a
very very instantaneous and simple view
of how democracy works and they thought
that by making a kind of like almost a
mental religious decision I mean it
wasn't a religious decision but it was
almost like a kind of religious decision
saying okay we're not going to be
hierarchical we're not going to push
each other around we're going to do this
as a democracy inside and they thought
that by making that mental resolution
almost like a New Year's resolution that
somehow everything would fall into place
and and there wouldn't be any hierarchy
emerging and in a sense what they did
was as a very interesting argument
by a feminist Guangzhou Freeman called
the tyranny of structureless
nests which is not exactly poetry but
it's an important piece of it's an
important piece of argument because she
says that by denying that there was
structure by denying that there was the
possibility of hierarchy people actually
disarmed themselves from recognizing the
tendency for some people to boss each
other around you know I mean and so
people would say no no I'm not being
hierarchical I'm just pursuing our
common goals or whatever but I'm
pursuing them better than you are and so
there were all the mechanisms that we
tend to use on each other to establish a
certain kind of ascendancy which people
were unable to to name the cat you
couldn't bail the cat because you'd said
well this doesn't happen this is them
this is the power structure that behaves
like this we have decided not to
therefore we aren't and I think that
that was a major factor another one was
the people were not reflective about one
particular thing and that is the
practicalities of running one of these
shows I mean you have to have some kind
of practical business sense I don't mean
some advanced commercial accountancy
sense but some practical business sense
about how to distribute a newspaper how
to get it printed how to paint the
printers how to just get all that stuff
organized and very often that was a sign
the people who did that were regarded as
the kind of the the second-tier people
these were the insignificant people and
the veil sort of demons of progress were
the journalists who talked and talked
and talked and talked and talked while
other people did and that was a
continuation of our kind of class
assumptions brought into the
organization of alternative media which
very often really fattened their
survival from within there is an
interesting point here though despite
all of the political repression of the
alternative media despite the all the
internal internal turmoil of the
different organizations that ran the
alternative media still they were
basically the investigative reporters of
the last few decades who have scooped
all of the significant stew
is of our era way before the mainstream
media just some examples it was first in
the alternative press we learned the
truth about Vietnam we learned the truth
about the Kennedy assassination that the
Warren Commission was questionable there
very well could have been a conspiracy
we learned the truth about Watergate we
learned about environmentalism the
problems of women of race of class the
native-american movement problems all of
these surfaced years before in the
alternative media than in the mainstream
media and to this day if you really want
to be informed in this society you have
to be plugged into alternative media
because the mainstream continues to
censor certain stories and simply not to
give you the information but despite all
the drawbacks and the problems that the
alternative media have had over the
years we should also give them praise
for the Vanguard role that they played
in this society in providing genuine
information but if you were to tell your
students or friends what alternative
media you would recommend to get genuine
information what would you recommend
okay in terms of print media I would say
the weekly in these times the up Nevada
which was mentioned earlier I think that
depending on your international interest
then things like the north american
congress and latin america report on the
americas this is a monthly I think the
merit Middle East research and
information project report which is I
think is it monthly or quarterly I can't
remember these days but anyway that's
really important on a very hot area of
the world right now and then they're
probably locally where depending where
you live there may well be some small
medical news paper that you can read
there I've been citing sources which
accessible nationally for the may well
be others locally which are important
what about those they keep up with like
the intelligence agencies like covert
action information bulletin for instance
sure I think it's amazing the amount of
for new and fresh information you can
get out of out of a whole variety of
these and of course there's a whole
bunch of environmental publications and
feminist publications as well these days
all of which are important to recognize
and important to keep up with in fact I
think alternative views has compiled a
list of alternative print media that's
accessible to the public that you can
write us and get a copy of we'll give
you that information at the end of the
show that will force you to keep
watching let's talk about public access
TV or you know in your book which was
that's the printed in what 83 84 84
public access TV hadn't been all that
well developed and you looked at kind of
the jaundiced eye Oh what has it
developed much now have you change your
mind about public access TV yeah I think
I have I think because they're now
something like I think it's over 300
public access channels inside in the
United States about over 2000 now it's
over 2000 well it's really grown so it's
a much more significant presence than it
was then also at that point the only
examples really Canada was something of
a front-runner in this and in the late
60s and early 70s but very often the net
effect of public access in Canada was
was not all that impressive at the time
so that would partly account for my
journalist attitude then today I think
it's very important because it is the
one video source where alternative views
small and large a can be seen and can be
can be heard there are of course a
couple of problems associated with it I
mean one is that you have to be able to
afford cable in order to receive it and
that immediately cuts out a bunch of
people right there and second of all by
the nature of the definition of public
access the time is shared with totally
repugnant organizations like the Ku Klux
Klan
and others and so it's a medium which is
also open to those people who are
actively seeking to oppress a section of
the population still further even beyond
the point at which they were pressed
already and so it's it's a flawed
situation but I still think that
unbalanced it's a very positive one it
certainly has been able obviate a lot of
the problems of the alternative press
particularly the print media because it
solves a problem of distribution access
to equipment at a very low cost or in
generally for free
and even we if we're lucky we raised
five thousand dollars a year and yet we
have a national distribution of our
program that goes maybe into 11 million
12 million households it obviates the
need for a big staff which in turn
eliminates those staff problems though
with which all the infighting and the
main Doug and I get along I mean we
don't have to don't have to to have
those problems individuals can make
their own stuff and put it right on you
don't have to have the great expense or
the time but there's nothing to be a
problem now with public access TV not
including the fact that their constant
attacks on it at the local state and
national levels at the regulatory level
at the judicial level and the
congressional level but there does seem
to be a problem with access that even
George stony he was considered the
father of access at NYU New York has
written about and I see it here in
Austin that is just the airwaves or the
cable time is best being taken over by
religious groups by people just doing
nothing and there's nothing of written
real significance I can silly or nothing
of reeling it was part of the society
goes so this seems to be a problem too
now
yeah I think part of the problem has
been in a way it's it's access has now
grown to be a kind of a micro industry
at least in some places I mean now
there's some access stations with
budgets of seven figures for the first
time and so somehow in the process of
all the fights with the Town Hall up and
down the place all the fights over one
program out of maybe 5,000 offering
whatever it might be frontal nudity or
some of the unacceptable words or
whatever that gets some local citizens
upset the process of all that a lot of
people have taken a very deficient
access of taking a very defensive line
and a very overly professionalized line
and said okay we'll just like the
telephone company we don't determine
what goes out we're simply a resource
and there's an element of truth in that
but there's also a very dangerous
element of untruth in it because I think
it is the job of people in excess to
make very active outreach efforts to
those communities historically
underrepresented in the media and to
make sure that those communities know
that they are welcome they are welcome
to learn how to use the stuff and how to
fill up the airwaves and begin to
communicate their concerns not only to
each other than that within their own
community but also to other communities
that that will I'm sure in many cases
respond to the expression of those
concerns so so there's a certain
responsibility it seems to me the public
access TV has to compensate for the lack
of democratic participation in the
mainstream media and that is that
democracy is a dialogue it's a debate
with all the voices in society
participating in discussion and
expressing their needs their problems
their views and since the mainstream
media cuts out so many groups certain
minorities certain people of different
political preferences certain public
interest groups it seems to me that
there's a responsibility for public
access TV to ascertain what the needs
are in their community what the
different groups are what the different
segments of the population are that
don't usually get their voices
articulated
then hand it's the responsibility of
people in those groups to take use to
take advantage of access and to use it
to articulate their views to the public
but it seems that all this needs to be
discussed between the access center and
the community so there is a certain
responsibility in public access to
really make democracy work when it comes
to the media and probably far too few
access centers take this Democratic
responsibility seriously which is why I
think you have the problem of just
getting overrun with garbage and missing
some of the things that should be seen
and heard in the community I couldn't
agree more there's always one question
and everybody's minds do who do anything
with either public access or with print
media you look to see how many copies
are are distributed you see a 2,000 or
5,000 here and they always tell public
access people well nobody's watching but
is there a public awareness of the
alternative print
well I don't think there's a public
awareness in the sense that if you took
a national survey that more than a tiny
fraction of the population will be able
to mention one single alternative medium
but at the same time I think that some
of that will be a misleading index of
the significance of these media my
example of choice is always that if you
take a trip up to Boston Harbor and see
the replica of the ship that they tossed
the t-shirts out of it is minut by my
standards it doesn't look as though you
get more in about five miles off shore
without maybe kind of being swamped by a
wave and the thought that something like
that would have made the journey across
the Atlantic repeatedly is hard to
imagine and I'm sure the the chests of
tea that they tossed overboard were also
pretty small they weren't giant kind of
containers the fact remains that the
significance of that small action on
that small boat in that small Harbor
kind of reverberating around America and
to coalesce a whole movement of
opposition to the profession which was
coming from George the third now I think
sighs what I'm trying to get to is that
I think size alone circulation alone is
not necessarily the only other most
significant index of of importance of
impact and I think that you know III
spoke earlier about the way the power
structure doesn't think that way about
these small scale media but I think the
other indices I mean maybe the power
structure could be long but I think
there are other indices because when
these media really become important
around a particular issue it is not just
those people who read them but those
people who talk to others and others and
others in a chain who will in a sense
allow that information to mobilize them
let me give you a very specific and
recent example as an outfit or public
data access and what they did was they
got information from central government
a federal government and put it on
floppy disks about the location of toxic
waste dumps and they found in the
process of doing this that most toxic
waste dumps are near ethnic minority
communities were geographically speaking
and they put the information not on some
national piece of some national document
they put it deliberately on local
documents because it's in local areas
that people are most likely to get up
some kind of upset and some movement
against the toxic waste dump people in
Austin are not going to demonstrate
against the toxic waste go waste dump in
Montana and vice versa but the the size
and the Localism of this particular
piece of information don't give you any
real measure of its potential impact at
least at the level of a given community
which is faced with this particular
toxic waste of which is threatening the
lives and health of the children and
adults in the neighborhood so sighs for
me is not irrelevant but it's only one
index of significance how do you sort of
appraise the
the role or the function of community
radio in the alternative media spectrum
well again I'm glad you raised it
because it's quite right with it's the
one medium we kind of left off to date I
think community radio is real important
I think that again the merit of radio is
that it's cheap its accessible therefore
to a lot of people without extensive
resources and I think that community
radio has a major part to play both in
delivering news and also in playing as
we know video is full of as purely music
these days but also in playing
alternative rock and alternative music
which doesn't get on the on the main
system in fact you studied some
alternative radio in Europe that's
actually very radical some of it is
low-power radio where individuals just
get a transformer out and shoot out
whatever political messages or whatever
music or talk they want to engage in can
you give some examples of that sort of
really radical radio that we're I
haven't seen anything quite like this in
the u.s. as far as I know at least okay
the the main examples from Europe and
now perhaps you know sort of have gone
by a bit in time I mean the the key
places were France and Italy initially
Italy both had a very strict law about
who could broadcast and basically what
happened was that first in Italy and
later in France people just decided to
break that law they saw it as a
ridiculous law a law which simply gave
the government of the day kind of free
reign just to express its own views to
the public and so they capitalized on
public discontent and broke the law in
that situation and eventually the law
would seem to be an ass in this regard
at least and was changed but for the
while there really was an explosion of
independent activity on the airwaves and
all kinds of groups would be involved in
in the social movements of the day be
they anti-nuclear will be their feminist
movements or a particular community
which was suffering a particular problem
or immigrants from the third world
immigrant workers from the third world
the variety of these interests could
find voice on these radios which
otherwise the Airways were totally
closed to them likewise in Japan there
are some examples of low-power community
radio we have a friend at tattoo
Kagawa who specialized in this and
evidently in Japan they got some very
cheap low power transmitters that
basically just began a conversation in
someone's home or maybe in a community
center and would invite people to come
and join in the participation the
community in the discussion and so a lot
of people left their houses and actually
became active participants in
alternative media as opposed to passive
recipients this became so popular that
Sony started to market these low power
transmitters with thousands of them all
over Japan and they were very very
popular this became a threat to the
government in Japan that carefully
controlled the mainstream media didn't
like these alternative media which
needless to say were very critical of
the government and were articulating
views have never been heard before in
Japanese society so they cracked down on
them pretty fiercely so this is no more
I've heard some stories about low-power
radio in the u.s. of this nature do you
have any idea of the extent or what type
there is there's Pacifica Radio which is
a national alternative radio network but
what else is there in terms of
alternative radio in the US well I
forget exactly how many stations are the
the I certainly runs into quite a few
hundred across the country there's
usually one at least in any major urban
center sometimes more share with Austin
of course is KCI fulfills that role
Pacifica is not a low-power station of
course own Pacific pacifica stations
broadcast on on slow regular wattage
low-power basically means that the
signal won't usually go
very far and I remember Tetsuo Kagawa
that you're referring to standing on the
roof of the house that I lived in
Brooklyn two or three years back and
broadcasting to the house of another
friend of mine two blocks away from
Flores and we were then picked up by
some other people in the neighborhood
who phoned in and said hey what's going
on this is amazing so it happens and the
transistor I mean I can show it since we
have a screen that the transmitter is
literally this big I mean about the size
of a remote or something for your TV
that's it's real small and there's a lot
of I'm not a technologist or an engineer
but there's a lot of Pettit ization
about how complicated some of the stuff
is and it really is not you don't need a
whole lot of wisdom or electronic
engineering knowledge to be able to put
one of these things together Jon when
we're talking about the future of media
in this society we need to begin to
theorize computers do we not because
this is a powerful new source of
information and it's against something
that is controlled by the corporate
mainstream that can afford these
expensive databases or these less
expensive like CompuServe and some of
the dialogues on the other services what
is the realm of alternative media in the
field of computers where do you get
alternative information FISA V computers
and how does this work well I mentioned
earlier a couple of these outfits which
have used one or other aspects of the
power of the computer to to communicate
horizontally instead of vertically piece
that and public data access and I think
that the the possibilities here are very
considerable as simple microcomputers
personal computers desk computers come
down in price for as long as they
continue to allow us to to use the
telephone lines without putting some
extra charge on then at that point
communication by these means it's like
having a data telephone and
communication by these means is cheap
and it's very quick and it's very easy
and so I think the opportunities that we
can sell
and there is an enormous amount of
activity today by the citizenry on all
kinds of bulletin boards and and
homemade databases of one kind of
another but again as you say if you want
access to the heavy duty information and
private information about corporations
and the rest of it then at that point
the same kind of privileged access to
media and communications and information
still operates on computer networks as
in any other sphere and that again is
something which should be a battle for
us to to begin to try to democratize
those sources of information and
probably one of the most successful
alternative sources of information is
piece net can you tell us a bit about
that so a piece that was begun in
California a few years back now and its
objective was to provide a network for
peace activists in this country to
communicate with each other to exchange
information about what was going on it
later brought in another network called
echo net as you see from the name of
ecological concerns and now it has
numerous groups on every conceivable
kind of political interests which run
their own bulletin boards and it's real
cheap it's only a few dollars a month to
join up and you can be plugged in not
only nationally but now also
internationally because it connects up
with a whole lot of similar networks in
Europe and Australia and elsewhere so
it's a very exciting new development and
essentially all it means is that instead
of hitting a few keys and calling up the
file with on your computer which you put
there yesterday you hit some different
keys and you call up a file which may be
located thousands of miles away and have
been created by somebody else and you
can access that and you can see it on
the screen if you want to print it out
you can print it out I continue to get
information about the Gulf from the
peace net database during the Gulf War
every day I would get alternative
information that was typed in from
Australia from the Middle East from
Britain from different alternative
sources they gave a very different
picture of the Gulf War then the Maine
stream media and likewise on
environmental issues on feminist issues
and all over the world in China in
Russia you have people in these bulletin
boards putting information and it's very
different than what you get from the
newspapers so I think this is a very
important source of alternative
information for the future from these
computer databases I agree and it's also
a medium of exchange it's not only
receiving that useful information but
it's also being able to give information
that's being able to ask people
questions be able to request information
exchange views and so on so it's in
principle a dialogic form of
communication which as he was saying is
the core of democracy in fact it's an
alternative form of democratic forum but
here people debate these different
issues during the Gulf War there was a
Mideast Gulf forum where people debated
that issue there's a palestinian-israeli
forum where people give different
opinions on this sort of thing there was
a presidential forum where people argued
out the relative merits or demerits of
Clinton Perot
Bush etc John what is the future of
radical media particularly in
relationship to society in your book you
say that media communications is the
fundamental element in the battle for
power and also power culture and
communications are induced highly linked
those are pretty
those are pretty significant things to
do with the media and particularly
alternative media well I think I also
say some of their the alternative media
flourish and the wastelands left by
official media and I see for as long as
official media and mainstream and
established media failed to fulfill the
objectives that they are supposed by the
sort of the the law LOV of our nation -
to fulfill as long as they they don't
fulfill those alternative media will
continue to flourish and they will
continue to be extremely important I
think that the
battle for power between the majority of
the society and the minority which
thinks that has the right under society
is crucially waged in the field of
communication because if the majority is
dependent all the time on media run by
and subservient to their minority then
our ability to want to know what each
other things to tap each other's wisdom
is going to be correspondingly
constrained